mein vortrag hat fünf teile zunächst
werde ich den übergang von der
essentiell ist ischen zu analytischen
anthropologie versuchen nachzuzeichnen
ganz kurz dann von der wie ich sind in
der analytischen anthropologie zur
philosophie der person dann von einem
song independence models einem
koinzidenz model was körper und person
betrifft ich wird es noch genau
erläutern dann werde ich mich mit dem
animalis muss und der konstitution story
kritisch auseinandersetzen die beide
versuchen eine antwort auf die frage zu
geben was personales leben ist ich werde
anstelle eines animalis muss eine
konstitution schiri versuchen eine
transformative theorie personale
identität zu entwickeln und abschließend
möchte ich noch auf normative aspekte
personale existenz eingehen indem ich
mich auf den begriff des personals pace
konzentrieren den jüngst maria fekter
eingebracht hatten den philosophischen
diskurs beginn mit dem ersten punkt
traditionelle philosophische
anthropologie hat im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert keinen leichten stand
teilweise wurde ihr disziplinieren
niedergang diagnostiziert teilweise
wurde ihr genuiner gegenstand durch den
angeblichen tod des menschen entfernt so
dass die rede vom wesen des menschen als
unkritisch weil essentiell ist ish und
im schlechten sinne des wortes an pozent
risch erscheinen muss mein beitrag lässt
sich dagegen einer tendenz innerhalb der
philosophie zu ordnen die ich als
analytische anthropologie bezeichnen
möchte analytisch ist diese neuere
anthropologie in sofern sie den diskurs
über das wesen des menschen auf
klassische themen der philosophie des
geistes der mit der physik und biologie
wie etwa personal identität
subjektivität oder materielle
konstitution bezieht und dadurch weiter
zu klären versucht kommt zum zweiten
punkt diese form von anthropologie die
analytische anthropologie weg sie nimmt
den begriff der personen als
systematischen schnittpunkt
verschiedener philosophischer disziplin
und diskurse dabei stehen folgende
fragen im zentrum sind wir personen
wesentlich tiere oder personen wir wenn
wir von uns sprechen
wie verhalten sich menschlicher körper
organismus und genuin personale
eigenschaften wie selbstbewusstsein oder
willensfreiheit zueinander
sind letztere bloß aktienanteile
phasenweise eigenschaften des ersteren
oder konstituieren sie eine eigene davon
unabhängige und theologische
wirklichkeit die analytische
anthropologie setzt also dort an wo die
traditionelle essentiell ist ische
anthropologie mit ihrer frage nach dem
wesen des menschen mit dem ende des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts nur ein
trümmerfeld aus heterogenen ansätzen
übrig gelassen hat und trümmerfeld ist
dieser begriff von herrn thies den sack
rede von einem trümmerfeld
worin besteht der unterschied von
traditioneller essentiell ist ischer und
analytische anthropologie er besteht
darin dass sich die essenziell ist ische
anthropologie als eine disziplin neben
den anderen philosophischen disziplin
wie ethik philosophie des geistes oder
und theologie versteht
gegenüber diesen horizontalen modell
verspricht die analytische anthropologie
nicht neben diesen disziplinen sondern
gewissermaßen aus und dank ihnen
sie ist nicht auf derselben ebene wie
die anderen disziplin angesiedelt soll
bezieht deren erkenntnisse von einer
metaebene mit ein und bezieht sie
systematisch auf dem griff der person
durch diesen systematischen und problem
zentrierten focus erlaubt es die
analytische anthropologie zur klärung
ihrer fragen auch auf lehrstücke der
gesamten philosophischen tradition
zurück zu greifen und die sind
rekonstruktive absicht neu aufzunehmen
kommt nun vom strong independence model
zum koinzidenz model zugrunde liegt
meinen beitrag die überzeugung dass
theoretische und praktische dimension im
begriff der person untrennbar
miteinander zusammenhängen und
aufeinander bezogen sind
maja jackman hat in der gegenwärtigen
debatte die häufig anzutreffende
trennung von theologischen unpraktischen
zugegen hinsichtlich personal in der
identität als strong independence model
bezeichnet eine haupt vertreterin einer
solchen auffassung ist im gegenwärtigen
die stewardess kurs christian cohrs grad
sie schreibt wie es reasons for personal
identity award metaphysik praktiken
konzeption of yourself and is not base
und metaphysik des grauens upgrade
praktiker da sagt also christian cohrs
card erikson wiederum nährt sich
personale identität ausschließlich aus
und theologischer perspektive an
wenn er gleich zu beginn seiner studie
mit dem titel sich jungen an
erklärt zitat main straight on the
physics of personal identity interleaved
jessica questions to small kompetent tu
dir weh auch wenn er das sagte auch wenn
er die notwendigkeit eines einheitlichen
betriebs der person eingesteht und
fordert er sagt dazu die tat know how
did i had been posted guarantees die
koinzidenz of what is important and
intellectual conditions for identity
authority mass biologie coherent es wäre
das erste klasse ich werde diese von
olsen formulierte anforderungen im
folgenden als koinzidenz model
bezeichnen und dem strong independence
model entgegensetzen
entgegen der tendenz personale identität
entweder nur durch rekurs auf
ökologische oder rein praktische aspekte
zu erklären wird sich mein beitrag
komplementär dazu der ontologischen
dimension personalität annehmen
personale identität annehmen und
versuchen daraus gerade auch die
praktische dimension weiter verständlich
zu machen
personale identität besteht demnach
nicht in klose und theologischer
identität hier droht die gefahr eine
substanz und theologischen
verdinglichung noch in rein praktischer
selbst konstitution hier tätige vereines
unter logisch und fundierten
konstruktivismus
vielmehr soll im folgenden durch eine
unter logisch praktische doppel
perspektive dem komplexen begriff
personale identität genüge getan werden
wie aber kann eine solche doppel
perspektive begrifflich gefassten auf
die einheit der person bezogen werden
die leitfrage des beitrags lautet daher
kannte zusammenhang von theologischer
unpraktische identität der person durch
rekurs auf einen bestimmten form aspekt
geklärt werden der mit dem spezifischen
leben das person gewöhnlich führen zu
tun hat diese theoretische praktische
einheit soll durch die entwicklung eines
begriffs der personalen lebensform
begründet und weiter expliziert werden
kommt zum nächsten punkt jenseits von
animalis muss und konstruktions theorie
ich versuche einen solchen begriff
personale lebensform entlang einer
prominenten debatte über die unter logi
personale identität innerhalb der
aktuellen analytischen philosophie zu
entwickeln
zwischen der position der konstitution
theorie
beckers und der dieser in entscheidenden
punkten entgegengesetzten position des
animismus eric sons
kurz gesagt besteht das problem bei der
position darin dass die animalis muss
personalität nur als aktienanteile und
phasenweise realisierte eigenschaft des
lebendigen körper organismus versteht
als als phasen zur tal während die
konstitution theorie den personal aspekt
derart über betont dass die personal von
dem lebendigen körper organismus
unabhängige konto logi konstituiert so
dass beide nur schwer numerisch
identisch sein können wenn becker
beschreibt die konzentrations relation
von körper und asyl wie folgt zitieren
konstitution many ways made it but it is
not the same relations identity mit
konzentrischen jobs simulator identität
in order to account für effektiv ex
konnte 26
special agent in germany properties to
dvd twitter account von effekt der fx
concept 26 cent 'wir dürfen kein cent
kennt survive defence of changes that
makes sense of constitutional
medienbetriebs ist es soweit becker
eriksson hat in der gegenwärtigen
debatte
diese auffassung kritisiert er schreibt
zur konstitution theorie folgendes zu
konstruktions relation schreibt tun hat
eines tenders relations and out put in
das thema block 6 in identischer
surrounding mit pearson in der jungen
einem guten ende gelangt hatte 51
but not that face tracking speaking pkw
ford ich werde versuchen zwischen diesen
beiden sich gegenseitig ausschließenden
position zu vermitteln indem ich ein
modell entwickeln da sich eine
transformative theorie personale
identität nennen werde und dass dem
problem bei der person entgegen der
position entgehen so abschließend zeige
ich perspektive und ansätze auf wie ein
übergang von der theoretischen zu
praktischen dimension durch den von mir
zu entwickeln inbegriff einer personalen
lebensform und per
soziale lebenswelt dem personal space
wie schlecht man ihn nennt
bewerkstelligt werden kann
ich komme zum fünften punkt eine
transformative theorie personale
identität ein transformative ansatz
personale identität wie in den folgenden
entwickeln möchte soll gerade dem
dilemma von reduktionismus und dualismus
hinsichtlich des verhältnisses von
körper organismus und person entgehen
wer sich beispielhaft in der debatte
zwischen animalis muss und
konzentrations theorie manifestiert der
gegenwärtigen diskussion würde für tier
wurde für theorien die ontologische
zwischen tier und mensch personen
unterscheiden
der begriff der additiven theorie von
rationalität eingeführt john macdougall
hat mit blick auf das problem der
wahrnehmung auf das problem von auf das
bei dem problem von wahrnehmung auf das
problem von additiven theorien
hingewiesen zitieren doch mal der
station think it must be possible by
stripping of special about us
im anschluss an mcdowell hat matthew
hoyle explizit additive theorien von
rationalität kritisiert und sich
insbesondere von modularen auffassung
menschliche rationalität abgegrenzt
beuel argumentiert dafür dass
vernünftigkeit keine zur tierischen
existenz modular hinzutreten die
eigenschaft oder vermögen ist sondern
vielmehr die tierischen vermögen auf
eine rationale weise neu konfiguriert es
handelt sich demnach nicht um eine
eigenschaft die auf derselben ebene wie
wahrnehmung oder wollen angesiedelt ist
sondern eine eigenschaft zweiter stufe
die diese eigenschaften erster stufe
determiniert eine vorläufer theorie
einer solchen transformativen auffassung
des menschlichen lebens findet sich
bereits bei herder findet sich darin
gegen einstufen china welches
tief zum tier die person setzt
stattdessen erblickt er ist ein
charakter der menschheit wie er sagt die
auf freiheit basiert er schreibt dazu in
seiner abhandlung über den ursprung der
sprache folgendes zitiere man nehme
diese ganze disposition seiner kräfte
wie man wolle verstanden vernunft
besinnung und so weiter wenn man diesen
namen nicht für abgesonderte kräfte
sondern für bloße stufenerhöhungen der
tier kräfte annimmt so gilt mir es
gleich es ist die ganze einrichtung
aller menschlichen kräfte die ganze haus
haltung seiner sinnlichen und erkennen
seine erkennenden und wollen die natur
oder vielmehr es ist die einzige
positive kraft des denkens die mit einer
gewissen organisation des körpers
verbunden ist verbunden bei den menschen
so vernunft heißt wie sie bei den tieren
kunstfertigkeit wird die bei ihm
freiheit heißt und bei den tieren
instinkt wird der unterschied ist nicht
den stufen oder zugabe von kräften es in
einer ganz verschiedenen richtung und
ausstellung aller kräfte und diese
richtung und aus wicklung der kräfte
könnte man einen transformativen aufsatz
ansatz nennen
das was herr der als einrichtung
charakter organisation oder haushaltung
bezeichnet ist nichts anderes als die
personale lebensform oder die personale
komposition des lebens die sich
transformative realisiert typisch
personale eigenschaften wie
selbstbewusstsein oder reflektierte
willentliche selbstbestimmung dürfen
demnach nicht als zum tierischen
organismus hinzutreten die personale
eigenschaften verstanden werden es sind
als ausdruck oder manifestation der sie
von deren personal lebensform
wie lassen sich im rahmen einer solchen
transformativen auffassung der person
die beiden probleme von animalis muss
und konstitution story lösen das problem
der konstitution story hatte darin
bestanden dass wir schon überzeugend
gezeigt hatte nicht ersichtlich ist wie
bei denselben materiellen bei derselben
materiellen zusammensetzung in einem
fall des auftretenden selbstbewusstseins
eine person im anderen fall meinen
körper organismus entsteht wobei beide
unter logisch verschieden sein sollen
die animalis muss hatte daraus die
konsequenz gezogen
das personal i tät nur in aktie der tele
1 schafft des organismus oder ein phasen
vorteil fatal sei vergleichbar mit einem
soldat der wiesn nicht ein mensch
und seine funktion als soldaten unter
bestimmten umständen etwa im kriegsfall
ausführt dadurch hatte er sich jedoch
verkauft das personal i tät kein
wesensmerkmal sein konnte
allerdings ist all signs animalis muss
nicht der einzige ausweg aus der
problematik der konstitution story
das lässt sich ein dritter weg denken
der einerseits ohlsson skepsis bezüglich
der konstitution story konstitution
relation aufnimmt zugleich aber seine
schlussfolgerung der personalen aktie
dental i tät zurückweist und gerade wie
die konstitution starry die personalität
für essenziell für unsere existenz
versteht gegenüber boyles
transformativen ansatz denn nur von
vernünftigen tieren spricht und nicht
den begriff der person berücksichtigt
soll dagegen der begriff der lebensform
eingeführt werden
der konstitution story und das animalis
muss steht demnach in einem additiven
modell die konzentrations theorie fast
das hinzutreten als essenziell die
animalis muss als akzent 11
es geht nun aber nicht um das
hinzutreten von eigenschaften wie mir
scheint sondern um eine konfiguration
oder transformation des natural
bestehenden es darf demnach nicht
natürliches leben von personal existenz
kategorischer begattung suisse
unterschieden werden sondern leben muss
als ein oberbegriff gefasst werden unter
dient das sich natürliches und
personales lebens subsumieren lässt der
zu leistende spagat besteht also darin
das verhältnis von lebendigen körper und
personen weder als identität zu fassen
noch als dualität wieder soll
personalität wie im animalis muss nur
als phasen total verstanden werden noch
wie in der konstitution theorie als
unter logische emergenz während der
animismus und theologisch zu schwach ist
ist die konstitution story unter logisch
zu stark im gegensatz zu boyles theorie
transformative rationalität muss diese
transformative auffassung der person
jedoch nicht nur auf rationalität als
systemisches vermögen sondern unter
logisch auf personally tät in ganzen
bezogen und damit systematisch erweitert
werden personally i tät ist gemäss eine
transformativen auffassung also nicht
eine ontologische zu treten
im agieren tags ist
sind eine bestimmte art der personalen
realisierungs weise der gattung leben
oder anders gesagt eine personale
lebensform